[Music]
Mike good morning how are you great
buddy how are you good I listened to the
interview with joe mixon and let me
start with how did that interview come
to happen in the first place well you
know I he's represented by an agent that
I think those know Peter Schaffer's been
in the business a long time and peter
has been trying to just kind of get the
word out Joe Mixon side of the story and
I've been very skeptical i mean we see
the video it's hard to come back from
that video it's a Ray Rice style video
and I think you could objectively look
at that video and say man it's even more
brutal than the Ray Rice video and I I
had had the opportunity to get mixing on
in the past and I finally decided you
know what let's go ahead and do it let's
let him since this week in Indianapolis
he won't be available to talk to the
teams in 15-minute increments as many
teams as would like to talk to him I'll
give him 15 minutes and I'll ask him
some of the questions that teams would
be asking and i solicited from multiple
different teams what would you ask this
guy if you had access to him this week
and everybody says what we would do is
get to the bottom of exactly what
happened that night so that's how it
came to be and that's why I decided to
go ahead and do it today yeah and you
pointed this out as I'm listening I'm
saying he's well-schooled because this
is what happens that you know the agency
will sit him down and say ah right here
are the questions this is what you need
to say full responsibility there were
catch phrases that were in there and you
tried to catch him off guard did you
have a moment where you sort of maybe
got to see behind the curtain with Joe
Mixon of who he really is well not
really who he is but whether there's
true remorse there it's hard to get
through the standard language that was
written by someone else and hammered
into his head to be used at the
appropriate time now look if he's true
it could be coincidental and he's truly
remorseful whether he's remorseful or
not these are the things that he's going
to say and I'd like to have more time
I'd like to have been in a setting where
it's not live where you can experiment
with different techniques to try to
break through and get a real human
moment out of the guy and get to who he
is I still don't understand and I look
at the one
that incident that's fine everybody
makes mistakes I understand that but I
still don't understand why the guy
didn't disengage he's bigger stronger
faster than the girl who was pushing him
he should have just gotten away from her
use your arm to block the blow and get
away and leave and that's the problem I
have with it I understand that it
happened and he he says all the right
things now but I still I I you know if
I'm bringing him to my city if I'm an
owner or a coach a GM I want to be
confident that's never going to happen
again and I don't know how you get to
the point where you're confident that
that's not going to happen when he's out
and about on the streets of his next
city if he didn't have this attached to
him where do you think he'd go in the
draft I talk to people yesterday who
think he would be a high second-round
pick and I know others would say higher
and it's hard to get to the truth this
time of year to everybody's full of crap
this time of year because their
strategic their full of crap anyway when
it comes to football but especially this
time of year when when the strategic
reality the draft is in play but I think
high round two would be a good target
maybe third or fourth guy if he was
clean but now the challenge is with him
not being clean which teams are going to
run the other way and which team is
going to be willing to take that risk
and put his name on a card and what
round will they do it he also have Chad
Kelly talented quarterback who's related
to jim kelly he's not invited to the
combine along with the jolie what is the
policy here with the NFL and who does
not get invited to the combine certain
types of criminal misconduct from the
past will keep these guys out of the
combine and violent actions use of
weapons sexual assault domestic violence
etc there's a lot of frustration though
coming from the team's about this policy
because these guys are still going to be
evaluated and if anything Chad Kelly and
Jill Mixon caught a break here because
they're not going to be put through the
gauntlet this week dan of 15 minutes
with this team and 15 minutes with that
team and 15 minutes with that team with
no cameras no microphones and already
you know we've heard from time to time
some of the crazy question to get asked
they're trying to peel through that
she'll of preparation and get to the kid
and you know that with a guy like this
who's bringing the baggage of the jewel
Mixon has to the table it's going to be
aggressive it's going to be ugly and
he's going to feel worn out physically
and mentally and emotionally when he is
done with that process and he should be
there the teams want him there because
the teams want to be able to interrogate
him one after another to try to get to
the truth and try to get to the real
human being and come away from the
experience with a conclusion as to
whether or not he's a guy that they
should consider at least continue to
consider possibly drafted but is this
fair this policy by the NFL to say to
certain potential draftniks that you can
ok they're still gonna be evaluated
you're not banning them it's it's it's a
PR move it's a reaction to the Ray Rice
video that's what it is and because they
were criticized so heavily for coming
off as insensitive when it comes to
issues of domestic violence they've
decided to boomerang the other way and
put a policy in place that just makes it
harder less efficient and more expensive
for the teams to do the evaluation that
they are going to do anyway you're still
going to evaluate the players it but
it's going to cost you more money
because now this is a guy that you've
got to fly them in if you got to do the
medical work on them in your own
building instead of having it done in
one place that's how the combine got
started dan it was a place to do
comprehensive medical on all the players
in one place instead of thirty two sets
of x-rays and thirty two sets of MRIs
and 32 this and 32 that you do at one
time and you share the information and
now that complicates it because he's not
available for the medical he's not
available for the interviews you know
all the stuff that they do on the field
is secondary to mainly the medical but
also for a guy like this the opportunity
to run him through hotel room after
hotel room and ask him aggressive tough
questions about what happened back in
July a 2014 one final thing you touched
on this on your show Adrian Peterson's
future doesn't feel like it's going to
be in Minnesota he gave us hints that
maybe dallas he gave us hints that maybe
the Giants so what what what is going on
with Adrian Peterson well then the
Vikings oh I'm 18 million dollars this
year and it starts with a six million
dollar roster bonus that is due early
next month look I think that and
we know that what happens this time of
year there's tampering it runs rampant
there are hypothetical phone calls you
gauge the market to find out what's
behind door number two if the team that
holds your rights doesn't want to give
you what's behind door number one and
for the Vikings they could say well we
only 18 million but we'll pay you nine
million just to throw a round number out
there the question becomes what what
other teams pay I'm starting to get the
sense and I don't know this but I'm
getting the sense that maybe Adrian
Peterson has yet to hear discreetly and
hypothetically and off the radar screen
from any teams that they would be
willing to pay more than what the
Vikings would pay on a reduced deal and
I think he's autumn only going to have
to decide does he take less from the
Viking or did you take even less than
that from someone else and I'm just
getting the impression that he he's not
getting the kind of value directed to
him that he thinks he should be getting
and it's probably going to leave him
even more motivated more upset to have a
big season if he physically can do it
but I have the feeling right now that
the money is not going to be there at
least not to the extent that he thinks
it should be thank you Mike great stuff
with a mixin earlier today you can catch
both football live with Mike on NBC
sports radio from six to nine a.m.
Eastern weekdays and also on NBCSN from
seven to nine thank you Mike thanks Dan
sleep up you know the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]